اهلا بك معنا سعاده السفير ولك خبره طويله
في كل من الخارجيه الامريكيه او البيت
الابيض وفي عده دول وكنت سفير للولايات
المتحده لدى المجموعه الاوروبيه وعند
الدول ايضا في البلقان واسيا وهذه الحقيقه
فرصه لنا في البعد الاخر للتعرف على رايك
في عده قضايا دعنا نبدا اولا من ملف
الساعه وهو ملف اوروبا كيف ترى وضعها
حاليا
اعتقد بان اوروبا
كلها تقف ضد سلوكيات الروسيه
فهنالك وحده كبيره بين الدول الاوروبيه
واستراتيجياتها يبدو انها ناجحه في وجه
روسيا
والكل كما نرى يقدم التضحيات
واكثرهم واقصد بشكل خاص الاوكرانيين
انه مافره على احتمار لكل
التضحيات ونحن نتعاطف معهم وكذلك نتعامل
اللاجئين الاوكرانيين الذين سيحصلون على
معامله جيده جدا هل هذا الموقف الواحد
لاوروبا هو برايك من جعل الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا تستمر حتى الان لانه في ملف
الحرب هذه كنا نعتقد حقيقه انها ربما
تستمر اسابيع او شهور الان دخلنا العام
الثاني كل المؤشرات تتزايد على كون هذه
الحرب مستمره هل توافقنا على ذلك
نعم وللاسف
نامل ان
وقف اطلاق النار سيتحقق ونعود الى طائرات
المفاوضات ولكن في الحقيقه لا احد يستطيع
ان يحدد متى سيحصل ذلك او كيف فلا شيء في
الافق يشير الى ذلك ويبدو ان هذه الحرب
ستدوم لفتره طويله
اغلب الاشخاص ما كانوا يصدقوا ان اي حرب
ستندل لان الحرب بهذا الشكل غير منطقيه
على الاطلاق
هنالك الشخصيه واحده هي التي تسببت بكل ما
جرى
بات جليا ان حساباته
كلها كانت غير دقيقه ولا احد يعرفهم
الحسابات التي قادته الى هذه المهمه
الانتحاريه والتي يحاول من خلالها احتلال
اوكرانيا بالقوه